paire de manches la parole est à
monsieur antoine herth assez monsieur le
président la question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture mais avant
tout je souhaite au nom du groupe des
républicains salue la mémoire de xavier
beulin président de la fédération des
exploitants agricoles décédé brutalement
xavier beulin est un homme de conviction
à battants qui n'a pas ménagé sa peine
pour porter haut et fort les
propositions et les revendications d'un
monde agricole en pleine crise à
quelques jours de l'ouverture du salon
international de l'agriculture
le titre de son dernier ouvrage doit
nous alerter
notre agriculture est en danger aussi je
voudrais interpeller le gouvernement sur
le paiement des aides de la pac ou
plutôt le non paiement
malgré les promesses réitérer les
engagements pour les années 2015 et 2016
ne sont toujours pas soldé alors que les
trésoreries des exploitations agricoles
sont exemptes pire voilà quelques jours
-les agences de services et de paiement
chargé de traiter ces dossiers a envoyé
quelques vingt mille courriers pour
demander des recruteurs de rembourser
des aides que certains n'avaient même
pas touché ces dysfonctionnements
répétés nuisent à la crédibilité de
l'action du gouvernement
ces dysfonctionnements jette un doute
sur la sincérité de nos débats
parlementaires
ces dysfonctionnements sont néfastes
pour l'image de la république
aussi monsieur le ministre quelles
mesures le gouvernement va-t-il prendre
pour stopper cette dérive l'état
monsieur andré vallini secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
tout d'abord excusé l'absence de
stéphane le foll qui est aujourd'hui
dans les landes à cause de la grippe
aviaire et je voudrais après vous
monsieur le député évoqué la disparition
brutale de monsieur xavier beulin
président de la fnsea qui est donc
décédé dimanche soir le gouvernement
tient à saluer son action déterminée au
service de l'agriculture le président de
la république et le ministre de
l'agriculture seront présents à ses
obsèques
en fin de semaine pour lui rendre un
dernier hommage et exprimer leur
solidarité à sa famille à ses proches et
aux membres de la fnsea sur les
paiements de la pac monsieur le député
l'état a pris ses responsabilités avec
des avances de trésorerie entièrement
financé sur le budget national et qui
couvre 90 % des aides attendues la
situation est aujourd'hui réglé sauf
pour quelques dizaines de dossiers qui
seront seules d'eau furent et à mesure
des déblocages pour ces dossiers a été
mis en place un fonds d'allègement des
charges pour soulager la trésorerie à
court terme des agriculteurs le
versement du solde des aides 2016 se
poursuivra donc dans les prochains mois
à commencer par les aides bovine viande
et lait d'ici fin février
concernant les courriers reçus de l'
agence de services et de paiement
courrier reçu par vingt mille
agriculteurs sur les trop perçus le
ministère s'est engagé ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de recouvrement forcé et le
recouvrement quand il est justifié se
fera sur les paiements à venir
enfin nous avons demandé à l'agent
comptable de la sp d'examiner avec la
plus grande bienveillance toutes les
demandes des échéanciers de paiement
pour les agriculteurs les plus en
difficulté et monsieur le ministre la
parole est à m